now for the main event
the speaking for the affirmative today's
school choice movement in the U.S is
worthy of support by Libertarians the
affirmative is being taken by Dr Corey
DeAngelis Corey please come to the stage
uh speaking for the negative uh Stephen
kinsella uh Corey Stephen Gonzalez
Stefan please come to the stage
[Applause]
um
right Jane please close the voting uh
all of you uh 700 people out there your
voting is being closed as well uh Dr koi
DeAngelis you have 15 minutes to make a
case take it away Corey
hey how's everybody doing
yeah
look we have a huge audience here we got
about what 100 Libertarians here in
other words we have all the Libertarians
in New York City that showed up
it's pretty great right I might actually
be wrong on that math there I went to
government school so I don't know if I
got that number correct but thank you
guys all for being here Gene thank you
so much for the introduction thanks for
inviting me out thank you Soho Forum
thank you reason Foundation as well for
sponsoring the event uh but Gene you
called me doctor I got to correct the
record really quickly I'm not a real
doctor
I'm more like a Jill Biden doctor
I have a PhD in education policy but uh
so I can't help you with the the
important stuff but I can help you some
math problems sometimes uh but look I'm
here to support the resolution that
today's school Choice Movement should be
supported by Libertarians and I will say
this is a debate that with an opponent
that I'm not used to I'm usually arguing
against leftists like Randy Weingarten
and the teachers unions and socialists
who want to trap kids in failing
government schools making the case
against school choice they argue this
this will defund and destroy the public
schools Libertarians might say yeah yeah
that I wish that would happen uh you
don't have to sell me on I already
support School choices is the meme these
days uh but look I actually like my
opponent today Mr kinsella thank you for
showing up as well it's it's great to
have a a strong opponent in this debate
on an important topic as well but look
we're having a lot of Victories on the
school choice front over the past few
years it's been a great time to be a
school choice Advocate it's because
people like the Randy Weingarten the
teachers unions have lobbied the cdcd to
keep schools closed as long as possible
why because they were able to secure
multiple multi-billion dollar Ransom
payments from taxpayers they're able to
say uh well we're not we're not open in
person even though the private schools
are right down the road because we don't
have enough money even though we're
already spending over eight eighteen
thousand dollars per kid in New York
City it's over 35 000 per kid in the
government schools just give us some
more and we'll open next uh a little
later never actually happened it was a
hostage taking scenario but the
unintended benefit was that families got
to see what the heck was going on in the
classroom family started to see that
even ones who had their kids in schools
that were a rated schools by the state
maybe they thought they were great
Public Schools they weren't as great as
they thought they were even if they were
doing well on math and reading parents
started to see that there was something
else going on another dimension of
school quality that's arguably more
important than anything that could be
captured by a standardized test which is
whether the school's curriculum aligns
with families values
pretty basic stuff votey bockham said it
best we cannot continue to send our
children to Caesar for their education
and be surprised when they come home as
Romans well the good news is parents
aren't surprised anymore they've woken
up they're never going back to sleep and
for far too long in K-12 education the
only special interest represented the
employees the adults in the system but
now the kids have a union of their own
and they're called parents they're a new
general interest not really a special
interest and we've had nine states in
the past two years alone past Milton
Friedman's vision of universal school
choice what do I mean by that Arizona
and West Virginia were the first states
to do so I Ohio being the most recent
and look you can take the funding that's
meant for educating your child to the
government school if you want you can
it's actually a fraction of the funding
in Arizona for example it's about seven
thousand dollars per students the state
portion about half of the total spend
and you can take it to the public well
if you want if you like your public
school you can keep your public school
for real this time I'm like with your
doctor but but if not you can take that
funding to something called an education
savings account that can be used to pay
for private school tuition and fees you
can use it for charter schools for
home-based Education options like
homeschool co-ops private tutors micro
schools which The Wall Street Journal
just wrote about today in fact they had
another editorial piece where they
pointed out that the it was the headline
was the teachers Union's tiny little
enemy they were referring to prenda
micro schools in Arizona that have
sprouted since the introduction of these
school choice education savings accounts
and what happened was the union had an
opposition research sheet on printed
microscope because they're so threatened
that their Monopoly is is not going to
continue it's going to crumble before
their very eyes and it actually is over
the past few years but that opposition
research sheet leaked to one of my
buddies went to the Wall Street Journal
editorial board and we got that that
funny headline I think the picture was a
an elephant that was frightened to death
of a little ant because any ounce of
competition is going to shatter their
Monopoly and and good
the main argument from the left is
they'll say this is going to destroy the
public school system but that doesn't
actually happen because uh of
competition 29 studies exist on this
topic and 26 to 29 studies find
statistically significant positive
effects of private school choice
competition on the outcomes in the
public schools too whether we like it or
not a lot of people like their Public
Schools I think it's uh more of
Stockholm syndrome because they're
forced to send their kids there they
basically have to pay twice in the
current scenario just imagine if you
were assigned to your nearest government
grocery store again government cheese in
order to stop getting poisoned by the
government food and more to go somewhere
else you had to pay twice for another
grocery store or get get this get up and
move to another area that's assigned to
a better government grocery store that's
probably going to fail in a couple years
anyway that doesn't make any sense at
all we don't do this with any other
industry in the United States but with
school choice that allows for more
bottom-up accountability families can
vote with their feet and uh it allows
for more equality of opportunity as well
because the most Advantage already have
school choice in the sense that they can
already pay twice they can pay for the
government schools to the tax system
while not using it and then paying for
private school tuition and fees out of
pocket this will allow for more families
that didn't have opportunities before to
have more uh educational opportunities
so it's been a great couple of years
it's become a political winner anybody
watch the midterms
uh I don't think the Libertarians won in
the midterms but there was there wasn't
a clear Victor in the midterm so people
were talking about a red wave right
there wasn't a red wave there wasn't a
Blue Wave but there was a school choice
wave
76 percent of the candidates supported
my Maya organization the American
Federation for children and our state
Affiliates won their races in 2022 and
we didn't just play in the easy ones we
targeted 69 incumbents in state
legislature legislatures for opposing
parental rights and education and we
took out 40 of them it's the hardest
thing to do in politics to Target
incumbents to take out a sitting
legislator and you don't have to take my
word for it of course Corey's going to
say this about his own organization's
track record just look in the liberal
tears and The New Yorker magazine where
the author lamented that yeah check this
out
education Freedom candidates fared
depressingly well in the midterms oh
well those socialists can just go cry
harder because also that although that's
bad news for socialists want to control
the minds of other people's children
that is good news for parents who want
more of a say in their own kids
education I better get to the arguments
coming from the libertarian perspective
that I think I'm going to hear from
Stefan consula that I've heard from a
few other Libertarians as well because I
don't think they're any good but it's
basically the way that I summarize it is
making perfect the enemy of the good I
think he uh the my opponent another uh
who's made who make this argument are
coming from good place we're both in our
co-capitalists we agree on the end goal
but I think we disagree on incremental
reforms and how we improve uh how we're
doing today but the main argument is
with government shekels comes government
shackles we'll look at the fundings
following the student you're going to
turn the private schools into public
schools and they're everybody's gonna be
worse off is going to have government
controlling all schools and we're going
to be screwed basically well I think
that's making perfect the enemy of the
good and one of the main reasons for
that is that we should take the
incremental win in the right direction
is that the government can already
regulate private and home education
today and they have historically think
about Oregon in 1922 the state outlawed
private and home education
uh entirely you had to send your kid to
the government schools was that because
of a school choice program in Oregon no
they didn't have any school choice
programs they still don't and they still
outlawed private and home education uh
thankfully three years later in a
Supreme Court case it's the Pure Source
of society of sisters where the court
famously ruled the child is not the mere
creature of the state they overturned
that bigoted law but they do so today as
well the government authoritarians in
office clamped down on private and homes
education and look where we're at today
in New York City they were coming after
this Yeshiva Jewish schools because they
were not substantially equivalent to the
government schools well the the Yeshiva
schools responded by saying well we
don't want to be substantially equipped
that's why we started these private
schools because we want to have a better
education than the one being provided
and we want to raise our children the
ways that we would like to do so
and New York has one of the worst
homeschooling laws on the books I'd say
the worst if you look at hslda's website
The Homeschool legal defense Association
the worst uh homeschooling law in the
country they don't have any private
school choice programs in New York City
uh but if you look at States like
Oklahoma Iowa Idaho which all have
Universal school choice what do I mean
by Universal every single family can
take their children state-funded
education dollars to the education
provider of their choosing public
private Charter or home-based education
option and they have the lowest
regulation of homeschooling in Oklahoma
Iowa and Indiana states that have
Universal full-throated school choice so
in general states that have more
education Freedom when it comes to
school choice also have less regulation
of home and and private education as
well and why what's the reason for that
look school choice Cuts against the
likelihood of government overreach in at
least three ways one you have fewer kids
being indoctrinated in government
schools being taught to like big
government policies they're going to
turn out to be a little socialist to
vote for big government later when
they're being indoctrinated in
government schools we have over 50 mil
about 50 million students being
indoctrinated in government schools
today this is an escape valve an escape
patch that allows more families to have
opportunity which might have more of a
free market type of education that
aligns with families values which is
more so with the general public than
with the socialists who think big
government is the answer to everything
politics is all about coalitions and
politicians respond to special interests
and pressure groups well if you have
more people using private Nome education
through school choice initiatives you
build a bigger coalition to fight back
against authoritarian government
overreach in the future
you know politicians don't respond to
logic they respond to power three you
have more people using private and home
education the concept becomes more
mainstream but the concept becomes more
mainstream the rest of society should be
less likely to call to regulated out of
existence it's not some icky thing in
the corner that only a few people are
doing now a lot of people are doing it
and even they do think it's still a
Nicky thing now you have a bigger
coalition to fight back against those
calls for for regulation from the
government uh and so this is an
incremental step in the right direction
and look Thomas Soule said it best there
are no Solutions there are only
trade-offs the people who are
fear-mongering about school choice a a
thing that we're actually winning on
finally something that we're winning and
advancing the ball forward on education
freedom is
um
they they're they're made they've made
perfect the enemy the good on the other
side but there are no Solutions there
are only trade-offs and what the people
are fear monitoring are saying is that
they're focusing on one potential cost
that could happen in the future while
ignoring the guaranteed cost of
cementing the status quo and by the way
I mentioned Randy Weingarten she'll
never show up to a Soho forum debate
let's just be honest right she she
disagreed to debating DeSantis Freddie
recently too but she'll definitely never
do this because they have no good
arguments to cement the status quo but
she's made the same fear-mongering
argument on Twitter now X and she gets
ratioed all the time by the way on
Twitter now X I mean she closes their
replies all the time so Elon Musk don't
get rid of blocking get rid of closing
your replies on Twitter that would be a
better alternative but she's made the
argument that this is going to lead to
government overreach in private schools
is she saying that because she's some of
narco-capitalist libertarian who hates
big government overreach obviously not
she's saying this she's a socialist who
wants to keep her gravy train going and
to cement the status quo Force kids
disproportionately low income kids to go
to their residentially assigned
government schools that are failing them
uh so this is an incremental step in the
right direction we shouldn't make
perfect the enemy the good we should
take the W or else we're going to be
stuck with the L and look not all school
choice programs are created equal look
at the law look at the bill and the ones
that are being proposed today and that's
what I'm defending today's school Choice
Movement is worthy of our support are
unregulated they have specific
Provisions look at the Arizona statute
for example the original statute has
specific Provisions to say that if you
accept the funding you're not a state
actor you're not a government school you
don't become a government School the
government cannot control your Creed
admissions processes Mission or
disciplinary policies Etc they have
anti-regulation language built into the
law so I think that's the kind of school
choice that we are pushing at American
Federation for children that's in our
model legislation it's also in the
institute for justices model legislation
as well
uh and so those are uh we we should make
sure to read the bill and these these
are our better proposals than than what
we've seen uh in the past and oh this is
all voluntary as Libertarians we should
be on board with things families making
their own individual cost benefit
decisions there has never been a school
choice program in the history of the
United States that forces you to take
the funding
and if they did I'd be against it too
but there's no such program that does so
every single family can take make the
cost-benefit decision for their own
children but as Libertarians we
shouldn't you know if you don't want to
take the money fine but you shouldn't
look to another libertarian or other
family uh regardless of their political
background and to say you can't take the
money I know you can't afford to home or
private educate your kid but you can't
take that money because I don't want to
do it for my own parents and with these
laws we've also seen a separation
between Home Educators and Esa students
if you accept the funding you won't be
defined as a home educator because of
the potential uh which hasn't happened
before but there has been the argument
that what if you don't take the money
and you still get the regulation one
that can happen without school choice
but two we've built into the model
legislation as well if you accept the
funding you're defined as an Esa student
student as opposed to a homeschooler
even if it looks like you're doing the
same exact thing that you were doing
before to prevent any regulatory
spillover from happening uh so I I think
I'll leave it at that uh thank you guys
so much for coming out uh all 100
Libertarians in the New York City area
look let's not make perfect the enemy of
the good let's take the incremental
victories I'm with you I'm in a
narco-capitalist as well but there
aren't any other better Solutions there
are some being proposed by Republicans
to use State Control to have a
one-size-fits-all curriculum to ban CRT
or to ban other things or to promote
American Education I think you're never
going to get out of this mess through uh
and the only way out is through Freedom
as opposed to force is to allow families
to choose the schools that best align
with their own values and meet their
kids needs in other ways otherwise
you're forcing everybody into a
one-size-fits-all system where you have
one group of people typically not even
the majority a minority has special
interests the teachers unions
controlling how to raise other people's
children for them
that's in the current status quo and
that's that you're always going to be
stuck with that problem with top-down
Solutions where Republicans have in
particular have uh tried to to tweak the
system in order to the better solution
is from the bottom up allow families to
vote with their feet Advance the ball
forward with education freedom and don't
force anybody's your view on anybody
else's children thank you guys so much
[Applause]
thank you Corey
speaking for the negative uh Stephen
kinsella take it away Stefan
all right thank you very much uh Corey
and Gene um I give up
just joking
all right so uh
so there are many ways to explain why
intellectual property is illegitimate oh
sorry that's the wrong debate
uh Corey started with a joke so I had to
try
um he's the expert so I had to bring
notes
okay the resolution is today's school
choice movement in the U.S is worthy of
support by Libertarians and I think the
way that this is worded unfortunately
gives me an advantage in this debate
okay to answer the question we have to
understand number one what Libertarians
should support which requires us to know
what libertarianism is and what today
school Choice Movement is so
libertarianism is a political philosophy
that believes in individual rights to
self-ownership
and in private property ownership we
call this
the non-aggression principle or we
basically oppose aggression okay so
Libertarians oppose a host of state laws
and policies since they themselves
commit aggression so for example we
oppose taxation War the drug war the
central bank and intellectual property
see it keeps coming up
um and another thing almost all
Libertarians oppose including Corey I
believe is public education which is
more properly called government schools
or state schools or educational welfare
so why do we oppose public education I
think of it as what I call the three C's
compulsory attendance laws compulsory
financing by taxation usually property
taxes and government control over the
curriculum
so the first two are unjust and
unlibertarian because they involve
aggression when you compel people to go
to school
that's aggression when you take money
from people by taxes that's also theft
or aggression and the third government
control is only possible because of the
first two if the government had no
ability to force
okay to force people into schools or to
tax people to fund it then they wouldn't
have any control there'd be nothing to
control
and of course this control results in
state propaganda and indoctrination in
the public schools so the kids learn
things like be a good citizen believe in
global warming and democracy sign up for
Selective Service to fight in the
state's Wars mask up vaccinate and lock
down when we say so okay so this
predictably results in education that is
too expensive inferior to private
schools and full of indoctrination and
state propaganda so it's no surprise
Libertarians oppose it so we oppose
public schools and we support
eliminating them or reducing it and
moving it to a private system so in
short we support separation of Education
in state
just like we support separation of
church and state
now if we had a state subsidized Church
system in this country like some
countries still do and like the US
actually did for quite a time after the
Bill of Rights was ratified in 1791
for example Massachusetts had a religion
called congregationalism which is the
official religion of Massachusetts
showing that the Bill of Rights didn't
limit the states but only the federal
government
would Libertarians now be arguing for
improvements to the system by
introducing Church choice or will we be
arguing for separation of church and
state I think it's obvious what we would
be arguing for
so what libertarian support is reducing
the three C's get rid of or reduce
compulsory
attendance get rid of or reduce school
property taxes and funding of
educational welfare and reduce
government control which would be
naturally come by reducing the first two
but you have to keep in mind that as
long as the government is paying there
will be control he who pays the piper
calls the tune
so what is today's school choice
movement and can we support it
my understanding is it's a broad attempt
to improve public education or
educational Welfare by various means
vouchers introduce suggested by Milton
Friedman in 1962 in his book capitalism
and freedom
and these vouchers can be used to go to
another public school a private school
for homeschooling for private tutors and
so on public Choice within the public
school system
tax credits and educational savings
accounts or educational scholarship
accounts or esa's which are tax funded
now why should Libertarians support this
do these policies get rid of or reduce
the three C's
well under this under a school choice
system education is still compulsory so
we don't get rid of that one and is
still funded for by taxes still funded
by taxes so the two C's are still there
so what about controls the state still
controls the public schools
so there's no reduction in control of
public schools in that regard
and I believe the state will have to
inevitably put additional conditions on
what private schools qualify for State
funding so school choice will increase
control
why for example did Hillsdale College
have to refuse
students who are being funded by
government guaranteed loans
because they were going to be controlled
by federal government regulations if
they didn't do that
just a few months ago as an example this
is in the paper recently the Archdiocese
of Portland Oregon which runs 15
Catholic schools there they terminated a
department that was insisting on the use
of preferred pronouns
no you don't have to have an opinion one
way or the other on this issue but you
can see that it's contentious
so the Archbishop declared that the
students in these schools had to be
addressed by their birth pronouns
instead of their chosen pronouns now of
course this caused an uproar
but if Oregon was funding all the
students in this school by a voucher
program Oregon think of Oregon and
Portland would they permit state funding
of a school that misgenders students
would the bishop have you been taking
those actions if he thought it might
jeopardize school funding
okay as for compulsory funding or taxes
in the current system educational
welfare is used by about 80 and 90 of
the students I'm sure Corey knows the
number that's the kids in public schools
whereas 10 or 20 percent are not using
educational welfare in a completely
full-fledged school choice system
everyone's on welfare so we've expanded
it from 80 to 100 so educational welfare
expands under school choice
no and what about the cost with the cost
of educational welfare that taxpayers
are compelled to fund would it go down
after expanding it to include private
schools and private school students we
all think about college tuition have we
seen it go up or go down in recent
decades as a result of government
taxpayer subsidies by guaranteed student
loans the GI Bill Etc I think it's
obvious what happens
and also the term school choice is a
little bit misleading it's like using
semantics to argue substance much like
in the abortion debate where abortion
rights Advocates calstr position is
pro-choice
or pro-life
well who's against Choice who's against
life so couching in argument that way
doesn't really help get to the substance
this is similar to how intellectual
property Advocates say this again keeps
coming up refer to patent and copyright
is as uh which are just state grants of
Monopoly privilege they call them
intellectual property to fool people
into thinking they're just a normal form
of property
so school choice Advocates say things
like well rich people have the choice of
sending their kids to private schools
why shouldn't everyone have that choice
well because it requires stealing money
from taxpayers and giving it to other
parents that's why
you could say rich people have the
choice to buy BMW why shouldn't everyone
have that choice
and if I have the choice to send my kid
to college why should everyone have that
choice
aren't there aren't there many calls
right now for forgiving student loans
and for making college free
paid for by the taxpayers in fact the
school choice esa's that Corey talks
about they're funded by taxpayer dollars
and they can accumulate money and here's
a quote from from the page of uh of the
organization queries with unused funds
can be saved for future K-12 and college
expenses okay so now we have taxpayers
effectively subsidizing college too so
it's just the beginning where does it
end
they also accuse parents of hypocrisy if
they send their kids to private schools
but they oppose extending educational
welfare Corey says this on a recent Tom
Wood Show episode 2211 and on a recent
Fox news interview criticizing Democrats
who oppose school choice
where he said to them apparently only
rich people should have school choice
now I'm not one to be shy about calling
Democrats Hypocrites and he's right but
parents but the reality here is what we
have is we have we have parents who are
forced to pay for other people's kids
propagandize government education and
who don't take educational welfare being
called hypocrites
I think not taking Warfare is a good
thing and even if they're Hypocrites I
don't think they're Hypocrites but being
a hypocrite is still better than being
an educational welfare parasite
we Libertarians have long opposed
welfare and things like food stamps
while vouchers and esa's are just
education stamps there's nothing
libertarian free market or pro-freedom
about them
some school choice Advocates accuse
opponents as Cory did today not only of
hypocrisy but of being purists or
absolutist to oppose even incremental
steps in the right direction they say
for us that the perfect is the enemy of
the good I don't think this is accurate
for example Libertarians who support
totally abolishing the income tax like
me
we support reducing it as well since it
moves in the right direction and it is
an unambiguous Improvement in fact
people that follow me on Twitter and
Facebook know that one of my mottos is
lower my goddamn taxes
but a tax reform that would lower taxes
for some but increase taxes on others
could not be supported because it would
increase the aggression done to some
innocent victims
so we favor incremental steps in the
right direction
what would that be for reform of public
education we have to move towards
separation of school and state or church
or education and state we have to reduce
compulsory attendance laws reduce
compulsory taxpayer funding not expanded
reduce government control of Education
libertaries support any incremental
incremental moves like this but school
choice does none of this
it doesn't phase out educational welfare
it expands it and entrenches it it
doesn't reduce control it expands State
Control to private schools it
effectively does turn
private schools into public schools
they may remain private and name just
like car businesses and fascists Germany
were nominally private but they were
still controlled by the state and just
like a privatized prison is still a
prison
so there's another semantic I must say
trick because I think their their
arguments are in good faith but there's
another semantic argument they use so
for example in a recent interview Corey
promoted a Texas school choice bill that
lets families quote access their
children's education dollars to take it
to the public private Charter homeschool
based education option of their choice
and the American Federation of children
his the group he's associated with
supports voucher programs that quote
allow education dollars to follow the
child their website says the money
doesn't belong to the government schools
education funding is meant for educating
children not for propping up a
particular institution we should fund
students not systems but this language
the money
doesn't belong to government schools nor
does it belong to the government nor
does it belong to families who happen to
have kids in public schools it belongs
to the taxpayers it was stolen from
Corey says the taxpayers already funding
the education of the child that same
money should follow a child to the
education provider that best meets their
needs what do you mean the same money
it's not the same money it comes from a
continual and repeated theft of
taxpayers why should it be the same
shouldn't our goal be to reduce this
theft so that the amount of money stolen
goes down over time instead of being the
same and just redirected so I don't
think the money should follow the child
they are no more entitled to the money
than the government is it should follow
the taxpayers
this debate doesn't ask whether parents
of kids in public schools should support
public choice
maybe maybe they would maybe they should
but maybe they would also support
increasing property taxes to make their
Public Schools better
just like college students with student
loan debt want their loans forgiven so
what what makes that a Libertarian
desire that some people want it in my
school district in Houston Texas Harris
County Independent School District HISD
in Houston with 200 000 students it's
the largest in Texas and the eighth
largest in the nation in 2012 1.9
billion dollar Bond was authorized by
the voters of course at my wife's
urging I voted against it although I
don't usually vote
um and the local high school near us
Lamar received 108 million dollars for a
new facility
which of course will be paid for out of
property taxes I voted against it and
naturally it passed because the majority
of parents who whose kids are in public
schools benefit from this welfare
redistribution and did did it cause
Lamar High School to improve I mean it
does have a nice 108 million dollar
building that I look at
um sometimes but should Libertarians
support this no
and maybe Social Security recipients
would favor increasing Social Security
payments but do Libertarians
this debate also doesn't ask whether
school choice might improve Public
Schools some Public Schools maybe it
would improve some Public Schools but it
might also make some Public Schools
worse imagine that you moved to a good
school district and you pay higher
property taxes and a higher value for
your house a premium to send your kids
to a good Public School
and now with this there's public there's
school choice and you have no automatic
right to send your kid there anymore
because it's too crowded with applicants
and they have to Institute a lottery
system and the value of your home
plummets because there's no there's
nothing special about being there
anymore
and this idea also would subject private
schools to board government control and
it would entrench the idea of
educational welfare it would make the
separation of school and state less
likely for example what happens if we
suggest abolishing Social Security now
it's the third rail for a reason
you can't touch it once it's once it's
once it's put in place how do Canadians
and Europeans react when you suggest
getting rid of socialized Health Care
system
you know they go crazy
imagine a world of 100 educational
vouchers how would we ever get rid of it
it would cause private school tuition to
increase Justice College tuition is
increased because of State subsidies
so the question is not whether it might
improve some schools it's whether
Libertarians should support the school
Choice Movement I say no the school
Choice Movement will damage private
schools and go to public schools
increase educational welfare and
entrench the idea of taxpayer-funded
state-controlled Education thank you
[Applause]
um
thank you Stefan uh Roberto Corey you
want to take the podium yeah
five minutes Corey
excellent points thank you so much for
bringing all that up uh look one of the
questions that was raised is shouldn't
we reduce the theft well if uh you pay a
little bit of attention to how the
school choice programs and bills are
actually written you'd know that this
does reduce the theft and there are 73
studies on the topic 68 of the 73
studies find that school choice programs
private school choice programs find
taxpayer savings for uh expansions of
school choice why is that because I
mentioned earlier eighteen thousand
dollars per student is spent in the
government-run institutions and a
fraction of that is tied to the student
in the form of an education savings
account in Arizona it was about seven
thousand dollars per student these bills
are written at the state level so it's
the state portion of funding not the
local and federal funding so it's uh a
taxpayer savings and as 68 of 73 Studies
have found in just basic logic 7000 is
less than eighteen thousand uh it should
make sense that this does reduce the
theft I've heard a couple of other
so-called Solutions one of them being
let's just eliminate taxes uh you dug
into some of my podcasts I dug into some
of your tweets which is my favorite
thing to do and one of them that you
said in June of 2020 was what this is
our this is the solution make people
richer so they can afford good schools
just be rich let them eat cake Marion
Antoinette would be proud increase
increase online tools and other
resources for homeschooling abolish
Public Schools abolish taxes
good luck with that I mean I'm I'm with
you I'm a I'm a an arco-capitalist but
go to us we have 50 Laboratories of
democracy in DC if you want to call that
a democr laboratory democracy as well
have we have we in any of those States
gotten to this goal and abolished public
schools and gotten rid of taxes
altogether no we haven't so the reality
is we have a choice set in front of us
do are we just going to screw ourselves
and let the teachers unions run rampant
and trap our kids in these socialist
institutions well they're they're going
to vote to increase taxes later on if
they learn in government schools that
big government is the answer to
everything the better solution is to
have an escape valve allow people to
vote with their feet and allow parents
to choose schools that work for them
another tweet in that same threads from
kinsella said I don't have any
expectations at all that any of this
will happen the abolishing property
taxes and whatnot I'm a realist so I
choose to make a lot of money so I can
buy my way out of this crap
good good for you but if you look we
have 50 million kids stuck in the
government school system we we need to
accept the incremental wins and look
I've heard some arguments from the other
from some Libertarians it's only a
handful I'll be honest where they'll say
that you know um this is out all just a
radical plot for the left to take over
the private schools well if that were
actually true and Randy Weingarten
actually supports school choice because
she wants to control the private schools
too if that were true white all the
Democrats almost unanimously vote
against it
um if they really thought that this was
their way to control private schools and
public schools you'd think all the
Democrats would be voting for it and the
teachers unions wouldn't be spending
tens of millions of dollars to stop
school choice whenever it's passed
they'd be promoting it not not going
against it Hillsdale College was brought
up earlier this had to do with federal
funds all of these programs are deal
with state level funding so this is a
federal funding issue and guess what
Hillsdale College got to say I'm not
taking the money
sounds sounds familiar what I said
earlier you can choose to take the money
or not just like Hillsdale did and we
should allow other people to have that
choice as well so this doesn't increase
educational welfare I mentioned that
earlier actually decreases it there's a
comparison to food stamps which I like
to use all the time but this is
different from Food Stamps because in
the default scenario with the food stamp
analogy in order to buy that analogy
we'd have to be assigned to
government-run grocery stores where we
get government cheese of course you
would accept an incremental step in the
right direction to instead of having the
funding let's say ten thousand dollars
per household per year going to a
government
cheese provider or grocery store giving
five thousand dollars per person to
spend on private providers of grocery
that's obviously an incremental step in
the right direction so is school choice
for spending less than we had before and
we're not assigned to government
institutions to get government cheese or
government education
um
BMW Choice again we're not assigned to
government providers of cars if we were
I'd rather have a voucher for half the
amount to pay for a better car the
government car would probably cost 300
000 as much as a Ferrari or more and it
probably wouldn't run just like with
education it doesn't actually uh we're
not actually educating the kids and it
costs a lot more than private school
tuition which is about 10 or 12 000 per
student we mentioned uh kinsella
mentioned uh the university analogy that
oh look if you subsidize universities
well the tuition might go well we've had
Decades of school choice examples and no
evidence of this you'd think there would
be some researcher finding that when
there's more school choice that tuition
went up we don't have any evidence of
that the burden of proof should be on
kinsella to show it to me but look in
the theoretical effect on tuition is
ambiguous because although subsidization
should increase prices increase demand
increase in Supply because of more
providers meeting that demand should it
decrease prices and competition should
have a negative effect on prices as well
so we don't know the theoretical effect
on price overall it's ambiguous and
there's no evidence that it's increasing
it and even if there was a small
increase in in cost
the overall cost is mathematically going
down because we're spending a lot more
in the government schools and this is
just one cost outweighed by the huge
benefits of giving families choice
[Applause]
all right
look those comments were before covid so
that's no fair the world has changed
I'd have to look at that thread
still just because consel is a jerk
doesn't mean Libertarians should support
this
look Hillsdale is I think maybe Grove
City did this too but as far as I know
Hillsdale is like one out of tens of
thousands or thousands of colleges that
have done this so the the pressure to
take free money when parents are
clamoring at your door is is uh is uh
hard to hard to resist so it's it's just
ridiculous to say private schools won't
accept this funding by and large so over
time it will get entrenched
um
listen
yeah we don't have uh we don't have a
government-run Mercedes dealerships and
grocery stores yet right now but the
logic of educational welfare is that the
government needs to fund it because it's
an important need right but education is
not the most important need in life it's
one of many there's housing health care
which we uh Health Care food and so once
you get this in in place there's going
to be a clamoring for well the
government's paying for education for
everyone because that's an important
thing why shouldn't the government give
everyone a voucher for food and why
shouldn't the government give everyone a
voucher for housing and transportation
and Health Care hell let's just make it
simple let's let's do Universal basic
income right which also Milton Friedman
also recommended with his negative
income tax idea so the end result of
this socialized system is to increase
socialism
right so we're going to end up having
basically literally communism or
socialism from each according to his
ability which is taking money from
taxpayers who can afford to pay it to
each according to his need his
fundamental needs
housing Health Care education so I think
that the problem with this is it is
going to result in an entrenchment of
the idea of government supporting
people's important needs including
including education I don't see that
anything about this all even if it
reduced cost in some in some ways it
would not it would not separate school
and state thank you very much
foreign
okay we uh we now go to the Q a portion
of the evening and again uh to uh please
line up in front of the mic with your
questions and again uh I uh I will give
special attention to questions that come
in from those many people who are
watching this virtually uh but uh we we
do have some people at the mic uh please
uh phrase your question ask a question
no need to identify yourself and if
there's anyone in particular to him
you're going to address the question
name that person what is your question
sir
is for kinsella
one of the things Milton Friedman did
suggest with regard to school vouchers
later on in life was that you could
index the vouchers to the rate of
inflation so that the
cost of the the actual you know cash
value of the uh voucher would decrease
gradually over time
and he would and you could allow that
people could contribute their own
private income to the voucher so that
over time the proportion of educational
financing at the state and local level
that comes from private money versus the
state money would decrease and
eventually just wither away would you be
in favor of that in principle
you got the question yeah go ahead
um well
you you could have that program and if
you actually put it in place I think it
would still have some cost I think it
would uh it would end up hurting the
independence of the private schools it
would have some bad effects on other
Public Schools it would centralize it
within a state the public school system
instead of the roughly decentralized
system we have now so I wouldn't say it
will be without cost but if it was
reducing taxpayer funding over time that
would be something in its favor
so you could do that but today's school
Choice Movement as far as I know is not
arguing for that they're not saying
um it costs 24 000 a year for a student
we're going to give them six and then
every year we're going to chop it by ten
percent until we're done with this thing
and the parents have to come up with a
difference because the the greater the
shortfall then the more the clamor is
going to be well this is only helping
the rich because only the rich can come
up with the difference so
I think you're going to have the
opposite I mean what do we have every
year with Social Security recipients
they want you to raise their benefits
every year because once they're used to
an entitlement they want it to go up
right and once every private school is
taking this I think their tuition will
go up so then we're going to say well we
have to uh we have to increase the
amount of the voucher so I I think
vouchers will grow over time once we
entrench this idea but yes I would be
happy if the goal was to lower it and
that was in these bills saying six
thousand five thousand four thousand two
thousand and ten years were done
coming from your Corey so it looks like
you came pretty close to agreeing with
the resolution because it's all these
programs are tied to a fraction of what
is being spent in the government schools
although it's not going down over time
so just to be fair uh but look
Libertarians if if we're I heard you
earlier just taking some shots at Milton
Friedman if we're going to exclude
Milton Friedman from our movement
if we're trying to build coalitions and
get things done we're doomed if we're if
we're excluding people like uh Milton
Friedman from the movement
question
yeah thank you both gentlemen for an
excellent debate really great arguments
on both sides uh this is for either of
you who want to take it on but uh Mr
kinsella when he put forth his argument
he gave us a definition of libertarian
that is maybe not uh the entire universe
of libertarianism it's a particular view
of libertarianism that might be termed
utopian libertarianism because it's it's
basically a view of libertarianism that
probably has never existed anywhere in
any place at any time so so I mean
unless you can show where this view of
the world has ever really existed
um you know the alternative is pragmatic
libertarianism which basically argues
that we should have you know a policy of
Freedom First uh you know so is this a
serious flaw in Mr kinsella's argument
that you know he hasn't gotten you know
he hasn't really included the universe
of Libertarians many of who except well
we have to accept democracy right so we
have to accept taxation as in rule of
law therefore let's just try to expand
Freedom as much as we can given the
political reality
um Stephen you you're the one who got
insulted there but let's let's
that Corey respond first and then you
can have your say go ahead a shot a
short answer yes
uh but now look yeah I I tried to say
this in the in the previous response
this is basically the no true Scotsman
fallacy that if we're excluding people
like Milton Friedman and saying that
even Milton Friedman's a socialist we're
not going to get anything done come on
most most Libertarians are not
anarcho-capitalists like like us too in
order if we want to get things done if
we're operating in the political system
that we disagree with uh even though we
disagree with it we have to build
coalitions because politicians respond
to power as opposed to logic so we we
need to have a bigger tent yes we should
have some you know
definition of what libertarian is to to
be quite expansive but not too expansive
to where we lose our our mission uh but
but we need to have coalitions in order
to advance policies that that improve
freedom
yeah I don't disagree with that I just
think we have a question about what
advances Freedom right so
um on the Milton Friedman issue I never
read him out of the movement as an
inter-capitalist as you are we're both
fellow utopians according to you
um I'm generous enough to include many
status in our movement or mini minica
sorry
um like Milton Friedman I just think
Milton Friedman is wrong about the
negative income tax and about vouchers
and about income tax withholding and a
few other things so he's not perfect
that's fine I'm not reading about the
movement
um
as for moving in the right direction yes
I agree first of all you have to define
the debate is about libertarianism so I
had to Define what it is I just simply
said Libertarians oppose aggression okay
that's not utopian that's a normal
Viewpoint and it doesn't even plenty of
Libertarians favored entering World War
II you know like Ann Rand you know was
in favor of you know so aggression is
not yeah well so so they want to reduce
aggression but they're not completely
consistent in principle that's the
anarchist point of view but we're
willing to include people that are 90 as
part of the movement that's fine I
simply said our general goal is to
reduce aggression and law I mean most
Libertarians do oppose the drug war war
at least confiscals or Taxation and
public education we all oppose that so
the question is simply given that that's
our set of values which I wasn't here to
defend libertarianism the question is do
Libertarians should they support school
choice so given those values should they
support school choice and they should
only support school choice if school
choice results in uh an improvement of
the situation in terms of those values
so that's all uh I have a question from
uh one of our virtual Watchers that's
clearly addressed to Stefan
Mr kinsella what if without Public
Funding half of kids just didn't go to
school at all is that a problem for you
well again I'm assuming that
Libertarians oppose public education so
I wasn't here to defend public education
or to defend abolishing public education
I'm assuming that most Libertarians are
already against it so that question is
not about whether we should do public
education by means of government-run
schools or by means of vouchers that's a
different issue but yes in my view we
ought to reduce compulsory attendance
laws and if that would and and make it
easier for children to work as well
because you can learn a lot by working
right so would I have a problem with it
yes probably in this world but I would
have a problem with people being poor as
well and I think the solution to that is
capitalism
having a rich society and and charitable
people that can help out people who need
help
comment from you quoting on that
question I know okay I will say EG West
in education compulsion in the state I
believe he wrote that before compulsory
funding of Education about 90 percent of
people were already
being privately educated anyway so I
think that helps my opponent's argument
but just something I was thinking about
next question so you got a point of
agreement between our two Debaters uh uh
next question sir
uh this is for Corey uh you mentioned
the ultra orthodox yeshivas
and do you feel that the society or the
government or Society
has any responsibility
to make sure that those children get a
secular education or the fact that they
don't and the parents agree to it is
that fine
they're not providing that in the
government schools and they're spending
thirty five thousand dollars per student
per year in those government schools in
New York city so I mean
you know I I don't I don't trust the
government to be the ones to make that
decision in general the parents are
going to know and care about their kids
more than anybody else particularly more
than bureaucrats sitting in offices
hundreds of miles away but if there's
cases of abuse or some you know obvious
aggression on the part of the parent to
the child then the government should
step in after the fact as far as a
pragmatic solution but yeah I don't
I don't think that putting this power
into the government's hands is actually
going to lead to the solutions that that
like you have uh put forward that this
is going to educate the general public
and all the government schools aren't
actually doing except for abuse you're
okay with the status quo any uh comment
from you uh Stefan about the Shivers
used the Jewish yeshivas in New York
City speaking as a non-jew that's out of
my expertise oh okay
uh I mean part of this is like the New
York Times did an article attack in the
Yeshiva schools and they said oh look
that you know some of them have zero
percent proficiency rates well and they
they you know call to basically regulate
them and it's like okay well the
government schools there's tons of them
with zero percent proficiency with a lot
less money more money per student they
don't call to shut them down they call
them to get more money oh we gotta give
them forty five thousand dollars per
student that'll fix the problems in the
government sector but the private sector
we got to shut them down or regulate
them to be more like these fantastic
government schools next door but part of
the argument for school choice and why
we've seen so much success over the past
few years has nothing to do with test
scores it's about being able to raise
your kids in ways that align with your
values people don't want to send their
kids to government institutions for 13
years without exit options to people
that hate them in their way of life
and until we uh understand that that
schooling is not only about math and
reading I mean look at Libs of tick tock
in the Twitter or X account it some of
the people in the school system see it
as a way to control the minds and to
raise other people's children school
choice allows some families particularly
lower income families to get out of that
cycle of indoctrination and it has a
side benefit as well of allowing for
those kids to be raised in values that
align with their parents which may be
more likely to call for Less government
regulation when they get up to voting
age yeah uh next question young man
sir
your question
this is for uh Dr DeAngelis you said
that I'm a Jill Biden doctor so oh sorry
um you said that you know School of
Choice vouchers would Implement savings
because it's only the state's half of
the funding that's being redirected is
there evidence of the taxes on the other
half being reduced to reflect this or is
this going into other aspects of the
welfare state well it depends on the
locality right they can continue sending
some of that money to the government
schools but they should also if that
does if that were to be the case that
would by definition increase per pupil
spending which should reduce the
likelihood of calls for Bond measures
and other increases in taxes they'll
have less of a leg to stand on and if
you look at how the bills are written
even if those schools kept all that
other money which they don't in general
it's a portion of what would have been
spent in the government School Stefan
said earlier in his rebuttal that or
maybe it was his opening that you know
first we're paying for 80 percent of the
families and now we're paying for 100 of
the families isn't that increasing
educational welfare no because they
mathematically put into the bills to
make it like let's say if you have nine
out of 10 kids in government schools 10
you're paying for that you want to ten
percent that you weren't paying for
before they would make it 90 or less in
order to force a fiscal taxpayer savings
so the the legislators writing these
bills and with our model policy too we
bake into the bill a taxpayer savings
and that's why no brainer we see 68 of 7
73 studies finding Financial benefits of
school choice saving taxpayer money
comment Stephen well even if it reduces
the cost I'm not sure if it reduces the
taxpayer savings because is there a
requirement for the taxpayers to get the
refund because I know that with the
patent office for example they make a
profit every year off of their
government provided Monopoly and then
the excess profit is diverted into other
government programs I'm sure the post
office is the same way when they have a
profit so I can't imagine that if they
had a savings they would just give it
back to the taxpayers I mean yeah they
could do that or they they could
redirect it to other uh works but then
that should also put a lower uh it you
should be less likely to call for more
taxation in the future for those other
works but yeah it depends on the place
uh next question
thank you for being here tonight
um
average American family can't afford
college with that
with that Federal subsidies and even
universities themselves can't afford to
refuse it the question is for Dr
DeAngelis do you fear that if those uh
normative legislations got passed by
either side of the political spectrum
that it becomes unaffordable for uh you
know schools to refuse that subsidy
because they just can't compete with the
price point compared to schools decide
to comply with those normative
legislations again from either side of
the spectrum is just impossible to
compete to refuse to be part of the
system I mean this reminds me of
something that was said by uh could you
I didn't could you could you summarize
the questions you understood would I be
worried about the pressure to accept the
funding because it'll alter the market
for private education in an area so
everybody would be incentivized to take
the money basically is that your
question yeah that it becomes
unaffordable to be not part of the to
refuse to financial aid right so I will
say we've had school choice for decades
so we've we've had the first school
choice program in the 1800s one in Maine
in Vermont called Town tuitioning
programs so we've had it for over a
century voucher programs and 31 States
plus DC already have some form of
private school choice nine of them have
full-throated school choice we've seen
this movement for decades and if you're
counting from the 1800s for over a
century we haven't seen evidence of this
I mean I've done studies looking at the
schools that choose to participate in
the programs or not one of them being
Louisiana in Louisiana only one out of
every out of the three private schools
in the area chose to accept the funding
so you still have a a vast Market of
non-participating unregulated private
schools and the other part of this is
that Supply isn't fixed you may look at
the current supply of private schools
and say well I don't like any of these
private schools but if you have a
voucher in the hand of the parent or an
education savings account well Supply is
going to meet that demand and they'll
have different curriculums than the
existing options they'll have especially
with with home education providers the
edge education savings accounts you can
use that homeschool co-ops and micro
schools which are really the biggest
threat to the the Monopoly in the um the
uh the teachers unions you're still
going to have a vast Market of providers
that don't accept the funding and again
yeah this is all voluntary all the
schools can choose to take the money we
don't have evidence of all of them
taking the money and
um
all the parents have a choice to accept
the funding or not and as Libertarians
we should we should
um
be okay with allowing other schools and
other parents to make that on their cost
benefit decision especially when the
default option is instead of allowing
parents to take a portion of that money
you're going to tell those parents well
you got to take all that money the 18
000 send it to the government
institutions whether you go there or not
I mean this is an easy this is an easy
step in the right direction to take
I was missing not mentioning that if
either of you want to put a question to
the other you can do so in an angel you
want to put a question to Stefan go
ahead
okay so to the best of your ability if
you had to choose one of these two I
asked you this on Twitter so you might
have remembered this one but it was
before the pandemic too so
um you didn't have a good answer for me
then so maybe you might have changed
that uh today but if you had to prefer
one over the other would you rather have
everyone assigned to government-run
grocery stores where you have to spend
ten thousand dollars per household for
every single family where you have to
get the government cheese or would you
rather have food stamps for everybody
at an amount of five thousand dollars
per household if you had to choose
between the two which would you prefer
it's hard to say I mean uh if assuming
there's still private grocery stores
that you can go to that are actually
nicer than the government cheese shops
uh and if I thought that this this food
voucher program would ruin the private
grocery stores
I I might have to weigh that against the
benefits of the more efficient
administration of this so it's called
welfare a follow-up do you think we have
food stamps today do you think that that
has ruined the private grocery stores
and changed how they operate no but 80
of the country is not on food stamps
um okay uh next question I'm just
curious uh who come to present vouchers
uh which one how they select which ones
to take how did Charter School select
their children their students if that's
the question yes basically yes yes a lot
of people coming how the kids chosen uh
Stefan uh Corey rather yeah yeah I mean
charter schools in general and you know
we haven't seen a lot of the victories
on the charter school friends but more
so Esa is giving the money directly to
the parents to go to private schools
charter schools are kind of these
quasi-public quasi-private entities and
in Most states they have to use random
Lottery admissions so when you hear from
the teachers unions that they're picking
and choosing their students that it's
the school's choice not the Parents
Choice that's actually not the case
because they use random Lottery but I
think it should be the school's choice
and that's why uh today's school Choice
Movement is seeing most of the victories
on the private school choice front where
they get to keep their disciplinary
standards they get to keep their
admissions processes and
um it you know there could be a
statement of faith as part of the
application it really depends on the
school it could be testing requirements
there's a whole host of different ways
that private schools could accept or not
accept students and I think that should
be up to the um the individual private
schools and that's how it is in most
places Carmen Stefan no I just have a
quick question for Corey um my
understanding is that at least since
some of these programs the way it works
out
some public schools have to Institute a
lottery because they have too many
applicants so if I'm living next to the
good public school that I moved into and
I would had basically a right to go to
before now I'm competing with people
from outside my district or my county
and so my chance of getting into the
schools lower and also I've unders I
understand that some private schools to
accept the the vouchers have to have
some kind of a lottery too or at least
at the very least it's going to increase
the demand for that school so other
parents who were going there before
they're going to have a harder time to
get in is there anything to that
argument yeah so private schools don't
have to use the lottery uh when
accepting voucher students they get to
have their admission standards and
that's in our model legislation and also
Institute for justice is model
legislation I I would have a big problem
if if they had to give up their
disciplinary standards and their
admissions processes but to your first
question about public school choice
that's again that's not really the big
thrust of the victories in today's
school Choice Movement this is more so
uh you know you can you can you you can
choose your your drink at dinner as long
as it's a Coke where you can choose
different government schools is
basically it's called open enrollment
and you know I think that's a step in
the right direction too but to get to
your concern is that one the district
the receiving District in a lot of these
places can choose whether or not to
accept that student and then also to
um
uh
the the students who are already
assigned to that school get preference
obviously uh to to be able to continue
going to the school that they're
originally assigned to so
um
yeah that's that's my quick response
next question uh Sarah yeah
assuming that the um assuming we get a
critical mass of children in private
schools homeschooling Etc such that
politicians are incentivized to regulate
and assuming that we have enough
government government money funding them
that they are incentivized to bow down
to the regulations and Obey them
couldn't parents use micro schooling and
homeschooling to create so many targets
for investigation and unenforcement or
I'm sorry and enforcement that the
regulations are unenforceable that they
can't find the kids yes uh sounds like a
question for Corey again yes yes
summarize the question for approach I
call it yeah just do it and see uh and
they're not going to be able to regulate
uh your your private and home education
providers because there's so much uh
right there's not enough enforcement uh
and so this is what Uber did right like
they would just go into cities and
expand and it's kind of like everybody
likes it you're not going to shut us
shut us down now so I think you can
imagine the same thing happening with
with the micro schools and I think
that's why today's school Choice
Movement is so important whereas the
voucher you had to get a ticket to go to
a private brick and mortar private
school well that doesn't open up the
market as much as a the funding goes to
a savings account directed by the parent
that can be used at private school if
you want but all these other providers
that are lower cost options in the form
of micro schools and this is just
another side benefit is you can get more
the money directly to the to the
teachers as opposed to the
administrative blow and spending all the
money on the fancy buildings and stuff
if you have the esa at a microscope
because they can do it out of their own
homes in some cases most of that money
can go directly to the teacher and in
fact Washington Post it's a trash
newspaper for so many reasons but they
had a good article during the pandemic
they outlined a public school teacher
that left the government school system
after being in it for decades they spent
over I want to say 20 or 30 thousand
dollars per student in New Jersey
government schools and this teacher
liked the microscope so much they wrote
they wrote an article about her where
she was making more money than she was
after decades in the government school
system had smaller class sizes five to
ten children as as opposed to 30 40 and
she had a lot less regulation and red
tape because she was able to control the
school and build the school that she
liked so this is a win-win it's good for
parents Libertarians students and
teachers as well even though it's not
good for Randy Weingarten who makes over
500 000 a year uh next question
yes this uh question for uh Stephen or
Stefan
um would you support school choice laws
in the case where only parents who are
net State taxpayers uh are allowed to
receive vouchers
uh that sounds to me like some kind of
approximation of a tax credit and uh of
all the aspects of school choice I would
never it's going to be hard to get me to
oppose any kind of tax break for anyone
thank you
just quick responses a lot of these
programs I don't have the statistic off
the top of my head but a ton of states
have tax credit scholarships and so if
we if you define that as being part of
today's school choice movement and some
of the recent wins in 2021 and I want to
say 2023 as well are funded through tax
credit mechanisms uh and basically the
way you do is if you contribute to the
scholarship granting organization you
get a tax break for doing so reduces
taxes but then those scholarships go to
students who apply for the funding so
it's all it's still private dollars and
as the Supreme Court ruled in ACS to V
win 2013 private dollars remain private
until they enter the tax collector's
hands so I think Stefan might be able to
be more on board with something like
that
I have a question a virtual question for
for Corey uh hasn't government funding
for college ruined college education
turning it into induct an indoctrination
camps might the same thing happen to
Elementary and high schools
yeah look I don't have as much expertise
on higher education but the funding of
universities I will say it is over
twenty thousand dollars per college
enrolled student per year more than what
we spend at the K-12 level and these
subsidies from what I can tell are not
directly to parents who can pick and
choose providers or students at the
college level it's a direct subsidy from
the government to the higher education
provider so I think the analogy is a
little flawed and more subject to
government regulation if it's going
directly from the government to the
school as opposed to to the parent who
then gets to choose different providers
but I don't know the evidence on how
and how much that has influenced the
curriculum at the higher education level
but it is different at the K-12 level
and we don't have any evidence of this
kind of government overreach happening
this fear-mongering if it were to play
out it would have played out by now
we've had these programs for decades
show me the evidence show me where this
has happened at the K-12 level instead
of resorting to other analogies
common seven now uh question
yeah this question is for Mr kinsella um
I just feel like maybe it's a very
simple question but maybe you didn't
directly address uh how if sorry your
argument seems to me as as your
opposition said to be
um you know the perfect is is should
should be the I'm praising this badly
but could you directly address the
accusation that you're that that your uh
proposals are in fact the perfect being
the opposite of the good and that
incremental change is is uh preferable
over no change uh is that that's you can
sell yeah I can reword it if uh yeah
you're asking me what's the response to
the accusation that which Corey made and
which others do that are sort of
intransigent position is um is taking is
being unwilling to make some incremental
improvements or basically letting the
perfect be the enemy the good in other
words because we really want to abolish
all government
involvement in education
um if we don't get 100 of it we're done
we're not going to be in favor of a five
percent Improvement
um I mean my response is we just
disagree on whether
school choice other than tax credits but
the school Choice Movement I mean if it
was just tax credits you wouldn't have
to call it school choice you would just
call it lowering taxes and and and give
the give the tax credit to parents who
people who don't have kids in public
schools too extend that tax credit but
um other than School other than tax
credits
um the disagreement is whether a school
choice would be a move in the in the
positive direction like I gave the
example earlier of if you favor 100
reduction in income tax you would still
take five percent because that's an
unambiguous movement in the right
direction so I wouldn't oppose that I
don't know of any libertarian who would
oppose that except for the the worse is
better crowd who want us uh to have Mad
Max world so that a Libertarian Phoenix
Will Rise From the Ashes those types
um
and um but the question is would this
would would school would vouchers uh be
an unambiguous movement in favor of
freedom right which is what Libertarians
it's not whether it would improve Public
Schools it's whether it would uh whether
it would reduce the problems we have
with public education would it reduce
compulsory attendance no would it reduce
taxpayer financing I don't think so
yeah just for the sake of argument
because I don't know how many of the
programs are tax credits let's say half
of them are tax credit Scholarships in
today's movement I will say in Oklahoma
they just one of the universal States
going all in passed a tax credit
scholarship for All Families uh so
that's a universal win that is a tax
credit in uh 2021 we had Missouri had a
tax credit scholarship these are off the
top of my head I'm sure we had a lot
more but let's say half of them were tax
credit scholarships would it be fair to
say that you halfway agree with the
argument The Proposal today because it's
today's school Choice Movement is where
the support of Libertarians if you
support tax credit scholarships and half
of those programs are tax credit
scholarships
did I get you to move 50 today I would
say it would make me less upset with
school choice
okay voters keep that in mind all right
that that concludes the Q a section
again I want to mention that both
Debaters will be at the reception
afterward and as you can see they have
both very approachable but we now go to
the summary portion of the evening uh
the affirmative goes first on summary so
Corey you have five minutes to summarize
your position
thank you
I don't think I need to give the five
minutes after the response to that last
question
uh but look again thank you guys so much
for having me out I will say I had a lot
of thank yous at the beginning of this I
want to thank one more person who's near
and dear to my heart there's been a lot
of things that have been going well over
the past couple of years the best thing
happened this year I got married
thank you Miranda DeAngelis for coming
out
[Applause]
uh but look the the today's school
Choice Movement is worthy of support by
Libertarians it's an incremental step in
the right direction we shouldn't be
making perfect the enemy of the good we
shouldn't exclude the likes of Milton
Friedman and others for not being a true
Scotsman we need to build bigger
coalitions have a bigger tent not a
smaller one if as a Libertarian Movement
we want to have more success look let's
take the W or else we're going to be
stuck with the L and what does that mean
it means we make our biggest enemies the
Socialists like Randy Weingarten super
happy that get to keep their gravy train
going look if you're on Randy Wine
Garden side on the school choice debate
and not mine maybe you're on the wrong
side
uh but look we've had school choice if
depending on how you look at it for at
least three decades or if you're looking
at the Town tuitioning programs for over
a century in the United States where is
the evidence of all these doomsday
predictions coming true it doesn't exist
uh Mr kinsella is a smart guy he would
have been able to find that evidence of
over regulation of private education at
the K-12 level as a response to school
choice I've already convinced them to be
supportive of today's movement at least
half of the way with the tax credit
scholarship victories that we saw for
example in in Oklahoma with their
Universal school choice tax credit
scholarship that passed this year look
the government can already regulate
private and home education they did so
in Oregon in 1922. that wasn't because
of school choice they outlawed private
school they outlawed homeschooling you
had to send your kids to the government
indoctrination camps that was because of
authoritarian government overreach that
wasn't because of giving families
additional choices in their family's
education it happens in New York today
worst homeschooling law on the books
according to hslda Massachusetts no
private school they have one of the
worst homeschooling laws in the books as
well you look at Rhode Island another
communist Utopia has another one of the
worst homeschooling laws on the books on
the flip side look at Oklahoma look at
Iowa look at Indiana they have Universal
school choice in all these states and
they have some of the most LAX
homeschooling laws on the books
according to homeschool legal defense
Association so if you look at states
that have more school choice more
freedom in choosing your child's
education you also have more freedom
when it comes to home-based education as
well and so let's not make perfect the
enemy the good that person wants some
school choice over here thank you very
much but
states that have more freedom in school
choice also have more freedom when it
comes to
homeschooling laws and I think the
reason for this is because school choice
uh Cuts against the likelihood of those
future regulations that we haven't
really seen playing out for decades now
I don't think when is it going to come
it hasn't come yet it's not going to
come anytime soon I don't think it is
but it we should be
um Vigilant in fighting against any of
those authoritarian regulations that
could be called for in the future I'm
there with you I'll fight with you
against any amendments to try to
regulate school choice programs out of
existence or to try to dilute them uh to
make them less effective and to make the
private schools more like public schools
but if you have more people using
private and home education that means
fewer kids in the government
undoctrination camps what does that mean
that means fewer kids being
indoctrinated to like big government
socialist policies that they'll vote for
later on in life let's say all you do
really do care about is reducing taxes
well you're more likely to get that in
the future if you have kids not being
indoctrinated in government schools
where they're learning that taxes and
government are the answer to everything
if they're being learned in values that
are aligned with their families which is
more aligned with not socialism you'll
be more likely to vote to reduce
government infringement in the future if
you have a bigger Coalition a broader
tent more people using private and home
education through school choice programs
you'll be more effective at fighting
against those future authoritarian calls
for regulation of private home education
I'm with you
uh but the better way to do so is
pressure from the bottom the teachers
unions have figured this out for a while
they use their members to Lobby to take
your rights away let's use our members
or school choice proponents and parents
to fight against those regulations we
can't do that if we don't
um have a coalition to fight against
those things if if more people are using
private and home education the concept
is more mainstream the concept's more
mainstream the rest of society should be
less likely to call to regulate out of
existence because it's not just a few
icky people in the corner but look this
reduces educational welfare if you want
to call it that 68 of 73 studies find
school choice program programs save
taxpayer money not and increase it and
uh look we've had school choice for
decades the the Doomsday scenarios
haven't played out if the Democrats and
really have this weird plot to take over
private home education why aren't they
voting for it uh look let's not
overthink this let's open a broader tent
bigger code Coalition let's win we
already are let's take the W and learn
how to do it as Libertarians and build a
big Coalition not a small one thank you
guys so much
[Applause]
all right
as I said in the beginning the worst
policies of the modern democratic state
are things like taxation War the drug
war Central the central bank and the
Federal Reserve intellectual property
and public education uh you can argue
about which one does the most damage
taxes War the drug war intellectual
property Federal Reserve or even public
education
so while we want to eliminate or
radically reduce all these shifting
public education from one model to the
other is not our major concern
so would I be upset if school choice was
adopted as I said not much I would be a
set of public education wasn't abolished
but if you do it this way as opposed to
that way I'm not that upset by how the
government runs it's it's uh it's
educational welfare system and at least
it pisses off the right people teachers
reunions Democrats and Advocates of
public schools so but we need to abolish
public schools in educational welfare
but the form in which we provided is not
the main issue so even though the
Socialist arguments against school
choice are usually bad doesn't mean that
there are not real problems with today's
school choice movement in the U.S it
doesn't mean that it's worthy of support
by Libertarians
let's imagine if Milton Friedman had
been around at the beginning of public
schooling in America and they had never
established public schools but simply
taxed people and gave every family a
voucher they could spend on private
school so now the country's has every
kid in a nominally private school being
funded by taxpayers there would be no
Public Schools officially and 10 times
the number of private schools that exist
today all being funded by the state it
would be educational welfare done by
market means
so would the private schools really be
private would they all not be subject to
various government controls would there
be separation of church of education and
state or would the state be intertwined
inextricably with education
would we expect vouchers to go gradually
down over time and finally disappear or
will we expected to be entrenched and to
grow over time as College tuition
continues to blow due to government
subsidies
as for other as and as other well
welfare programs like Social Security
and socialized medicine become
impossible to dislodge once put into
place would a Libertarian be happy with
this Universal voucher-based educational
welfare system or would he oppose it I
think the answer is clear
supporting school choice ultimately
means supporting A system that will at
best end up in Universal tax-funded
voucher-based educational welfare where
the private schools have simply become
the public schools so what do we favor
how should we perform our abysmal public
school system in my 2020 comments I
didn't know I was going to have a debate
with Corey so
um yes you can't just say abolish
government schools and abolish property
taxes if you really want to achieve
something but we can do things our main
goal has to be to separate education and
state and to reduce or eventually
eliminate all state involvement in
education we have to dial back
compulsory education requirements reduce
State funding of educational welfare and
property taxes so as I mentioned I
wouldn't be in favor of a school choice
program that says every parent gets a
very small amount and they can make up
the difference
and but it's got to go down by 10 every
year so that it's gone in 10 years
unfortunately I think that this is not
going to happen with any of the school
choice programs they're going to be put
in place and if they're successful it's
going to be in place forever
they don't want to put in motion a plan
that reduces the overall tax burden over
time and phases it down to zero they
don't want to eliminate Public Schools
they just want to improve it
okay instead of agitating to expand the
public school system to include and
swallow the private school system
instead of agitating to expand the
number of students receiving educational
welfare we Libertarians should be
arguing to reduce the size and scope of
government schools cut their funding
don't expand it and shift it to cover
private schools defund the government
schools cut school funding cut property
taxes rinse wash and repeat so for these
reasons I believe today's school Choice
Movement is in the U.S is not worthy of
support by Libertarians thank you
[Applause]
foreign
Jane uh please open the voting again yes
no or undecided on the resolution
today's school choice movement in the
U.S is worthy of support by Libertarians
and again our 700 virtual visitors are
probably going to decide the outcome
this evening but I have in my hand the
soil form Tootsie Roll that will go to
the winner I'm going to toss it at him
when I get the final vote from Jane
meanwhile again I want to encourage you
to attend the food the drink the
merriment the the further intellectual
discussion
Among Us and with our two Debaters both
of whom will be attending our after
party follow the crowds it's 55 great
Jones Street 2 blocks of town from here
should be easy enough to find follow me
I believe Stefan knows where it is Corey
does Corey follow Stefan in this regard
okay and you'll find it uh and that's
where we can continue the discussion uh
meanwhile I want to cordially invite you
all to our next debate especially our
two Debaters might be interested in a
September 18th debate Monday September
18th in this Hall between yaron Brook
and Brian Kaplan both of whom are well
known yaren Brook will defend the
resolution
Capital capitalism would definitely be a
complete disaster for Humanity
that will be defended by yaren Brook and
opposed by Brian Kaplan September 18th
in this Hall
Wednesday uh that yes Wednesday October
18th we again we do a debate every month
uh Wednesday October 18th Mark Mills
versus Rosario vertuno Mark Mills will
defend the resolution
between now and 2035 electric vehicles
in the consumer Market will likely
disappoint environmentalists by
remaining a product bought mainly by the
well-heeled minority again between now
and 2035 electric vehicles in the
consumer Market will likely disappoint
environmentalists by remaining a product
bought mainly by the well-heeled
minority that's Mark Mills defending the
resolution against Rosario Fortuna
October 18
2023. uh yeah this year of course
Tuesday November 14th we will have a
debate with the resolution reading
artificial intelligence
poses a threat to the survival of
humanity that must be actively addressed
that a resolution will be defended by
Susan Schneider opposed by Jost land
grebe that's November 14th a debate on
artificial intelligence
Sunday December December 17th for the
second time only we're going to do an
experiment with a matinee that will be
Sunday afternoon at 3 P.M on December
17th and that debate will be to be
between law professors Kate Clinic
versus Jay bhattacharya the debate
resolution reads the making of national
International internet policy was
hindered rather than helped by the July
4th Federal Court ruling that restricted
the Biden administration's
Communications with social media
platforms and that resolution will be
defended by law professor Kate Clinic
opposed by Jay barucharia as many of you
know in that Federal Court ruling
epidemi epidemiologist Jay bhattacharya
who has appeared before in this forum
was a plaintiff in that particular court
ruling of July 4th uh I I'm looking for
Jane uh how are we doing on the voting
uh chain yeah oops
looks as though we need the drum roll
please
yeah thank you
well again uh the the resolution uh read
today's school choice movement in the US
is worthy of support by a Libertarians
the yes vote went from 44.9 to 64.3 it
picked up
19.4 percent picks up 19.4 percent of
the vote so that's the number to beat
the no vote went from 10 to 23 percent
it picked up
13.3 percent pretty close pretty close
but 19.4 beats
13.3 the Tootsie Roll goes to Corey
DeAngelis thank you
[Applause]
and please come to our after party
two blocks Uptown see you then
[Applause]